I won't intentionally [ __ ] you over if
you don't [ __ ] me over okay steel we're
gonna pull little messages out of this
little container and we're gonna spin
the wheel but we're gonna see who we're
gonna die blissing I'm most nervous
about my grandparents I have the numbers
to all of my exes and I am not homies
with them at all
what about to put you unless a much to a
little nervous just the idea of like
giving you my phone makes me nervous
anxiety there yeah all right let's do it
really get in there deep where did this
game come from this seems like not a
good idea
this is I honestly can't stand sex all
right I honestly can't stand sex
- your mom's she's gonna be like I don't
even think you were dating anyone you're
still selling drugs oh yeah
are you [ __ ] me oh you don't even
have a text history with no I know
oh so I so I just sent you still selling
drugs to to his eggs do we have to play
this game I hope that there is no
response can I get a picture of your
feet this is good number neighbor I'm
gonna spice it up a little bit I like it
can I get a picture of your feet you
know how I like it
when was the last time you were cuddled
oh that's gonna doraville why are you
getting adorable one cuz I'm cute that
would be a good change solid oh well all
right
oh wow good so I'm gonna text your ex
when was the last
I'm sweating right now still want to see
those pic smiley wink face oh no papi
guys don't want to see those pics winky
face I'm gonna do still want to see
those fixed dot dot dot dot opening up
with something that's maybe serious I
don't know oh oh my ex attacked me back
she said was that for me
oh okay yeah of course it was what
should I say you should say Donald Trump
is my celebrity crush how many times do
I have to tell you I'm not having sex
with you
my mama she's gonna be like very
concerned about my online dating I am
now texting Alana's mom how many times
do I have to tell you I'm not having sex
with you and I'm hitting this end I hope
you like bananas cuz I'm bringing the
heat god I hope you get X I ain't gonna
get chance
oh no no no no I hope you like bananas
I'm bringing the heat
how much are plungers this is urgent
okay ladies that would be a good tweet
asking you shall receive just tweeted
how much are plungers this is urgent and
all kappa ah i've never thought you're
all that great honestly
cut Sakura I mean even if I sent it to
my boss I think you would feel bad oh
sorry grams grandma I love you just let
me know that this will be a fun drinking
game this is a party is a sleepover game
it's like an emergency contact list but
like much more personal and terrifying
we might have ruined your family
relationships and maybe you know stirred
up some old flame but I have fun my
grandson is in danger and I told them I
said I'm gonna go back and tell em you
are in dude
you
Oh